let's come to this kind of wedge here
what you want to get Oklahoma oh my god
someone from Oklahoma I know nothing
about that state because you're not
important on the global scale would you
dare would you tell me something about
Oklahoma that nope more like no claw
Homer if you ask me I don't know why I
made you from the South I'm sorry if
you're not I did not know we had the
Oklahoma tourist Borden who Oklahoma the
center of the Dust Bowl family in 1907
guys this is a riveting star guys in
this kind of wedge here front to back
what you want to hear rapper the French
Revolution wow you in fact very posh
person okay the French Revolution
Oklahoma home of the Dust Bowl founded
in 1907 middle of the room what's it
gonna be one second you're not in the
middle of the room crop circles and
Monet who will combine those will have
Monet crop circles Monet crop circles
French Revolution Oklahoma one person
over there yes you just really love the
French Revolution bit don't you guys
over here which one rapper so many at
the same time I heard Kylie Jenner what
did you say Tide Pods who Kylie Jenner
eating a tide pot highly generating a
tide pod Monet crop circles French
Revolution Oklahoma and over here which
one high heels
where okay one second you can keep
shouting it but I'm not taking it
because we've already got Kylie Jenner
and I don't know how big her rear is I
don't know you said placenta you said
high heels one of them is you know a
shoe and the I was trying to think of a
joke there I mean were Kate I think is I
think the centers an excellent
suggestion but high heels did come first
so I'll try and mix them both in I'll
just try and make it savory because that
does sound horrible
I always isn't it because people know do
they one here keep the placenta yeah did
anyone eat it that's a thing by the way
in LA especially people they keep it in
they eat it which which seems I just
thought it was weird
Haley Jenny's uh placenta it's so
strange because what if it was delicious
that's not a reason to have more
children just like get pregnant again
I'm addicted
that's disgusting I'm sorry so high
heels and placenta Kylie Jenner eating
at iPod Monet crop circles the French
Revolution and Oklahoma this then lovely
people of the Comedy Cellar this is some
fun this is gonna be a freestyle rap
that Iran made up on the spot based
entirely on their suggestions not
prepared and it's gonna be amazing shall
we drop that beat should we drop that
beat guys read let's roll that and let's
show them how we do I'm really excited
for this this is gonna be great
well start with yours yeah I travel wide
and far but I will never go there sorry
to disappoint you [ __ ] Oklahoma
yeah I might come across as unpleasant
it's like a hundred something years ago
1907 I visit and that's my gold what is
it Chris well it's the home of the Dust
Bowl in the Great Depression everybody
died no crops they were raising nobody
Drive no survivors you can go to
Oklahoma Rissa musical as well on stage
I could show you they revived it on
Broadway one guy over here giving it
hand up in a wave like yeah to Broadway
you're hurt oh I cut shapes like a mad
crop circle you might say that my art so
silly but I like to make the circle in
the shape of a lily pad you can call me
man a the best French impressionist from
back in the day he paid on plein air
who's doing all the lily ponds people
said to him here you are a silly man you
did the circles wrong get a weird yield
you've got a lay the wheat down now in
the field and if you see Mel Gibson in
the film signs he's the main guy
the sign of the times took a baseball
bat and killed the extra-terrestrial he
probably thought it was a junior he's
anti-semitic he's a really bad guy we
should cut him down we should all rise
like they did in lame is back in the day
we're in the French Revolution building
up the barricades everybody laying down
the monarchy Marie Antoinette she was
saying freely let them eat bread I can't
do the accent I never studied it in
school I'll attack him
they were like down with louis xvi
downwind beside down with the Sun King
who'd storm the Bastille who free all
the prisoners I've got some dirt on my
clothes I'll make it glisten here I'm in
the laundry feeling really odd by the
way i'm kylie jenner I see a tight pod
like oh my god it looks so savory I
wanna pick it up and insert it in me it
looks like it tastes amazing like a cow
just gonna go down and start grazing Wow
I get what the praise about it's so damn
tasty when it bursts in my mouth you
wait I start to feel asphyxiated I need
to go to the ER no hesitation meditate
on it be at peace but sadly the tide
provides the sweet release of death and
off she goes you know I went there
blasting I like to get the placenta
Ronna dry freezing
make it to a shape off to the Louis
Vuitton store I take and say I'm gonna
give this to you and can you turn it
into a pair of shoes they say no Priss
that would be so wrong I take the
placenta to Louboutin and I give it to
them yeah you thought I've forgotten the
center on the shoe that's why it's red
on the bottom
I would not have a walk